so far the only confirmed TV leaders
debate of this election is a
head-to-head between Jeremy Corbyn and
Boris Johnson the German leader Joe
Swenson says that's unacceptable he's
prepared to take legal action against
ITV to challenge the decision the TV
debate about who will be the next prime
minister of our country cannot and
should not exclude the only woman leader
who is able to be the next prime
minister because I stand as a candidate
to be Prime Minister and as the leader
of the biggest and strongest party of
remain it is a nonsense to suggest that
these debates should go ahead leave
versus leave with no voice for remain
whatsoever television debates with all
the main national party leaders have
only happened once that was in 2010 Sky
News is now hoping to replicate that
with a three-way leaders debate at the
end of November in a statement the head
of Sky News John Riley said Sky News
originally proposed a debate between the
leaders of the current government and
the opposition however as there are now
multiple proposals for double headed
debates we believe it is sensible to
suggest an alternative approach that
will allow the public to properly
scrutinize a wider range of views we
will continue to provide appropriate
coverage to other parties in our
broadcasts over the election period the
Lib Dem leader accepted the invitation
immediately but no response has yet been
received from the other two leaders and
concern has been raised by both the SNP
in the brexit party that they too should
be invited
last year Sky News called for the
establishment of an independent debate
commission to be backed by parliament
and funded by broadcasters the Liberal
Democrats say the current argument over
debates shows why such a commission is
necessary every year there is a
kerfuffle about are they going to happen
how are they going to happen what are
the rules by which you know the idea
that we are now in a position where
we're looking to take ITV to court
possibly over
it just shouldn't happen so if we had an
independent commission that interpreted
the rules set out by Ofcom independently
in advance then I think it would just be
so much calmer previously the idea of an
independent commission won the support
of both mr corbyn and mr. johnson we've
always wanted debates between leaders
not just the party leaders but also with
the spokespersons for different
departments and so that there is an open
public debate I've certainly support
Skye's campaign to have an independent
american-style Commission - to make sure
we get it right but since the December
election was confirmed labour and the
Conservatives have not shown any
inclination to take part in debates
unless they are head-to-head without
other party leaders representative Tom
Rayner Sky News Westminster